anthony you became teammates with kobe  bryant back in the 2012 olympics he was  a big brother to you  for the rest of your time through new  orleans and then coming to here  i know that you have been thinking of  him you told me before the nba finals  i cannot let him down anthony you did  not let him down what does it mean to  you  you know ever since the tragic tragedy  you know  all we want to do is do it for him and  we didn't let him down  it would have been great to do it you  know last game in his jerseys but  you know it made us come out even more  aggressive even more powerful  on both ends of the floor to make sure  we close it out tonight  and i know he's looking down on us proud  of us  i know you know vanessa's proud of us  the organization's proud of us  you know it means a lot to us  it's a tough moment man before you want  from me  say  [Applause]  he was a big brother to all of us and we  we did this for him before